in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I respond to a question from
social media will we answer only using
emoji stay tuned to find out as you may
have noticed most of the topics we cover
on this series come from real-world
issues that customers and developers are
running into for example Edie Robinson
here asking for some content on how to
profile google cloud functions Edie
thanks for watching here's what we've
got for you Google cloud functions is a
service offering on Google cloud that's
still in beta at the time of this
recording as such there's still some
things that need ironing out but in the
meantime here's some great ways to get
the info on the performance of your
functions in order to get a base level
understanding of how your GCF code is
performing there's two things to look at
first you can view your cloud functions
with their execution times and execution
counts in the cloud platform console
from here you can get aggregate
performance information about how long
it took to deploy your function as well
as how long it took to respond to a
request now there may be situations
where you need to output some content to
your logs in order to help debug or mark
specific events calling the console log
function in GCF outputs a line to the
logs which you can view in the GCP
console at the time of this video full
stack driver tracing is not integrated
with functions however if you're looking
for more information there's a couple
things you can do until then first is
inline function wrapping us since GCF
logs can be read via the gsutil api it's
straightforward to wrap core parts of
your functions with timer statements and
log those durations later you can walk
through that data and check out how each
area is behaving or import all of your
logging data into bigquery and do even
deeper analysis second is emulator
timings it turns out that you can do a
quite a bit to profile your code locally
through the emulator before actually
deploying it technology like the v8
profiler can help a ton here although
you might need to modify your code to
get it all working and of course the
execution times won't be exact since
your local machine may have different
performance characteristics than those
in the cloud but you can still get a
good sense of where the hotspots are if
you'd like more information about these
tools and some other ways to profile
your cloud functions check out the
article
in the description below and in the
coming weeks I'll be taking a look at
few of the most common GCF performance
issues here on cloud performance Atlas
so stay tuned because every millisecond
counts